pese a la lluvia miles de personas
marcharon hoy en París en este ocho de
marzo para exigir a los derechos de las
mujeres mujeres pero también hombres
familias e incluso niños con un lema muy
preciso este 2023 esa oposición a la
reforma de la julilaciones de Manuel
macron que va a penalizar sobre todo a
las mujeres por sus permisos de
maternidad y también aquellas que
realizan labores de ayuda a la persona
de limpieza que muchas veces trabajan en
negro y van a necesitar trabajar muchos
años más para poder gozar de una pensión
completa pero vimos también otras
reivindicaciones gente pidiendo más
justicia en el caso de violencia contra
las mujeres e incluso solidaridad con
mujeres de otros países dirán de
Afganistán las mujeres kurdas o una
persona que hacía limpieza la asamblea
nacional nos pedía por la igualdad de
salario en este año 2023 en Francia en
paralelo el presidente Manuel macrón nos
rindió homenaje en el Palacio de de
Justicia allí es el alimí una abogada
feminista fallecida en el año 2020 y
anunció su intención de poner en la
Constitución Francesa el derecho al
aborto una iniciativa en este sentido
está siendo discutida justamente por los
diputados y los senadores
[Música]